pour clôturer ces lui 10 days le réseau
des médiathèques a sorti le grand jeu
le mu mais d'accueiller une nuit
consacrée à l'amusement pour tous les
âges
le but c'est vraiment de s'amuser tous
ensemble et de montrer que les
médiathèques sont des lieux qui
accueillent le jeu aussi bien que des
livres et que le jeu est un produit
culturel comme une sorcière malines
parfaire son jeu d'acteur pour un jeu de
rôle où sa stratégie pour un jeu de
plateau les jeux sont faits sultan vient
de battre sa maman en fait faut isoler
un peu l'adversaire dans un coin et
thuram et le t as they be et après après
tu les renverser sur les côtés plus loin
à del se laisse prendre au jeu de cette
impressionnante structure
apparemment c'est un navire en 3d bon on
essaie d'arriver au milieu salade après
impossible pour ceux qui se veulent plus
vieux jeu l'association name cochaux
proposait de retomber dans des pixels
pas si lointain alors là en fait on est
venu pour amener nos enfants pour leur
faire plaisir et résultat on s'est mis
devant l'as bien console de notre
adolescence et on a perdu nos enfants ou
présentent des anciennes machines qui
ont fait l'histoire du jeu vidéo sous la
forme de bornes de démonstration et les
bancs de démonstration c'est ce qu'on
pourrait trouver dans les magasins
quand les consoles sorte l époque
et fin des jeux de mots cette année les
lyonnaises ont réuni plus de 4600
personnes